- Deux centres de distribution
Amazon ont été partiellement
fermés à Brampton à la suite
d'éclosions de COVID,
et une dizaine d'autres lieux
de travail sont sous enquête
dans la Ville Reine.
Depuis vendredi,
toute entreprise ayant
cinq employés infectés
ou plus dans les régions
de Peel et de Toronto
devront fermer pour 10 jours.
Dr LAWRENCE LOH, médecin
hygiéniste de la région de Peel
- Nous avons beaucoup
d'éclosions dans des lieux
de travail.
- À Peel, le taux de positivité
au virus est supérieur à 20 %,
et la plupart des personnes
infectées le sont sur
leur lieu de travail.
Pour Radhika, ces nouvelles
mesures arrivent trop tard.
Son père est mort en février
après avoir contracté la COVID
à l'usine pour laquelle
il travaillait depuis 26 ans.
- We need all of the companies
in the GTA to be held
accountable.
- Les fermetures en cas
d'éclosion devraient devenir
obligatoires partout dans
la province, selon elle.
Cela nécessite toutefois
un soutien financier
pour ces employés, qui
devront s'isoler chez eux,
en attendant le programme
de congés de maladie payés
promis par le gouvernement Ford.
- Dans ce décret et
une recommandation forte
aux les employeurs pour donner
les salaires aux employés
touchés par ces décrets.
- L'autre point d'orgue est
de commencer la vaccination
de ces travailleurs essentiels.
PETER JÜNI, directeur du groupe
scientifique de l'Ontario
- Si on vaccine les travailleurs
essentiels et leur famille,
les bénéfices vont être
présents, pas seulement pour
eux, mais pour toute la province
parce qu'on est capables
de contrôler la pandémie.
- La vaccination commencera
dès la semaine prochaine
dans les installations
des Fermes Maple Lodge, à Peel.
Les entreprises Amazon et Maple
Leaf Foods de la région, aussi,
commenceront bientôt à vacciner
leurs employés.
Ce programme pilote
doit permettre de vacciner
des milliers de travailleurs au
cours des prochaines semaines,
avec l'espoir d'être ensuite
étendu à d'autres lieux de
travail de la province.
Ici Camille Feireisen,
Radio-Canada, T